15 to 30 year old dudes that were cool
did not collect cards in the 90s and now
a lot of them do you have some of the
people that are just hardcore flip for
money money is their whole life that
went from cards to nfts they're doing
real estate right now like you have that
crew but it's crossed the chasm of like
pop culture and now we're in this really
nice spot where there's still a [__]
load of people interested more and more
every day and that's a big deal
collecting I believe in 15 to 20 years
it is a cultural genre that you will go
out to dinner to meet somebody at a
business meeting and I believe people
are going to ask people hey what are you
collecting how's your collection going
between art and watches and sneakers and
Handbags trading cards Beanie Babies
didn't work out but plush toys are
forever the teddy bear Raggedy Ann
digital Collectibles will be here for
the rest of our lives trading cards at
the show everyone's like where do you
see the future of the Hobby in five
years do you think it'll be around them
like it's been around since the 1860s
there's been trading cards they were
presidents and animals back then now
they're athletes in pop culture but